everyone's throwing their hat in the
ring to host The Wheel of Fortune
oh is that right Whoopi wants to be the
host oh then she can ditch the view I'm
sure she wants to get out of there oh
I'm sure she's sick of that
everybody wants the job because they
know it's easy and it's yeah 15 million
dollars a year it's such an easy gig and
it's like wow 15 million a year for
doing that but you know hey maybe it's
more difficult than you think but I
doubt it what he is so beloved I think
maybe they might give it to her how do
you say no to Whoopi Goldberg hopefully
wheel's got an envelope somewhere that
says what to do
I want that job
Stephen A Smith threw his uh name into
my mother loved Wheel of Fortune loved
Wheel of Fortune she really really did
and so did I
I want to throw my name into the Hat
I ain't trying to give him my day job I
ain't trying to give up my podcast but I
gotta tell you if Wheel of Fortune
called to ask me
to host the show of for a couple of days
I wouldn't mind I wouldn't mind and I
wouldn't mind hosting that show while
folks try to figure out what those
letters mean
he's gonna yell at people no you gotta
you gotta be chill top contenders are
Ryan Seacrest
Whoopi Goldberg coming in at a big
number two
see that's why you got to throw your
name in because all of a sudden Whoopi's
number two Stephen A Smith that he's on
there Pat's daughter Maggie say Jack
and Vanna White and on the outside they
say JD Harmeyer JD wants television yeah
Judy give us a couple of lines if you
were the host of uh Wheel of Fortune uh
all right let's see what is it um what
are some of the thoughts
that they do uh uh all right uh things
Tommy your first spin the wheel
I'll tell you what I'll do for you
if you want Robin and I will play Wheel
of Fortune and you could be the host and
we'll see how you do all right okay
okay don't worry let me think of a art
all right I got
okay I mean do we have to prepare it
though yeah
are you ready yeah I'm ready I got it
all right
okay ready places places
[Laughter]
yeah well if you're JD you better say it
10 times okay
Howard your first up at the wheel all
right thank you JD I'm spinning the
wheel
does it have
an awesome Wheels stopping on first wait
a minute a thousand dollars
oh thousand dollars right does this
place have an R JD
no no ours
Rob sorry it's my turn that was good JD
That's Italian Robin your turn
oh
350 dollars
okay JD I'll uh
uh say r
oh my God Robin you're the worst
contestant contestants on Wheel of
Fortune you just [__] up good no are
there any yards JD
once again there are no r's
[Laughter]
are there any R's
JD you were really good at that you were
really good at that I I just know how
Pat I just seen Pat do it you know he
just barely does anything except now if
I had to talk to the contestants that's
a whole different story you'll have to
go like uh
uh all right Howard uh I understand uh
I understand duh I understand
I do JD I love to paint in fact I paint
watercolors and right now I'm painting
one for my wife a beautiful little bunny
named Jessica Rabbit oh that's very nice
sure she'll enjoy it and uh Robin uh it
says here you're uh you like tennis you
love watching tennis uh you have a
favorite tennis player apparently yes I
have a lot of favorite tennis players
but right now I'm watching this young
man named Carlos Alvarez and uh I think
he's gonna be the next big thing in
tennis all right so yeah is everybody
asleep at this point by the way uh JD I
understand you once got a tongue up your
ass
[Laughter]
I'm not a contestant
foreign